perdre un enfant je veux dire c'est pas
dans l'ordre des choses moi tous les
soirs j'embrasse la photo de mon fils je
pleure le matin je me lève je pleure à
la fête des mères mon fils m'a manqué
[Musique]
on comprend pas pourquoi la techniques
d'interpellation qui est la clé
d'étranglement n'a toujours pas été
interdite car quand on a pu le constater
c'est ce qui a tué mon père qui
rejoindrait une fracture du larynx et on
aime ta leur incompréhension aujourd'hui
[Musique]
monsieur matheron faut arrêter la clé
d'étranglement parce que vous êtes un
meurtrier si vous continuez à la laisser
vivre
on ya laissé aucune chance aucune aucune
chance de survie puisqu'il a crié il a
crié j'ai tout vu et tout et tout
j'étouffe j'étouffe veto j'étouffe et
d'en bas on y va en continu en fait faut
aider les policiers carrément j'ai envie
de vous dire faut les aider à pas
devenir des meurtriers faut les aider à
prendre conscience de la valeur de la
vie faut les aider faut leur rappeler
qu'elle est leur métier faut leur
rappeler pourquoi ils sont là